these are the types of conversations
that we need to be having As Americans
with the debt that we're taking on in
America right and the situations that
are going on in the banks over the last
few years the the whether it's cultural
issues like the wokism stuff and lgbtq
and critical race Theory and all these
then it became abortion and covid and
Jabs and oh nfts and meta world and I'm
buying real estate in the [__]
metaverse who gives a [__] this is what
makes America tick these are the types
of issues that we really need to focus
on great point and get on the same page
here not all the nonsensical stuff like
I just bought an nft in the metaverse
with a covet mask attached to it like
that's like let's get past that and get
back to reality here I think that's very
important
[Music]
thank you